early 2000s when we would have met
like how loaded would you have been
on drugs or what yeah or money
no no no i mean i mean like
drugs how rich
um
but uh you know i don't know well back
then like
i was always stoner um i had a lot of
fun with pills narcotics for a long time
and that almost [ __ ] killed me so i
think i got out of that
alcohol was i used to tell you i don't
drink because i don't like alcohol well
i drink when i play shows well i play
shows 10 months out of the year
you know
was like [ __ ] i'm like you know you walk
around like i don't drink that much all
right you know but i'm like [ __ ] i kind
of i've had my time you know and uh
i'm just thankful that i got out of it
decently clean you know but i'm
yeah it's hard like you know it's like
it's [ __ ] hard to be young traveling
around with a job where you don't really
have a boss you know right and you're
kind of like rewarded for being a
[ __ ]
you know and you work one hour a day and
you could choose if you even want to do
that you know
right yeah yeah it's so funny like uh i
went through the airport with somebody
and uh
they're like oh i got wheat on me and
i'm like you have weed on you through
the airplane like yeah you can't do that
and it's like you guys grew up in the
generation where you were touring where
you couldn't even like smuggle dude weed
through the airports one time because we
would get these [ __ ] um
we would get these like private like
shuttles at airports so kids wouldn't
bother us yeah and so i remember this
one time i had a bunch of weed in my
suitcase
and because you know whatever they don't
i could see them checking my pockets and
my carry-on but the shuttle group with
just our band took us into a private
office and said okay they're going to
bring security and just check your
luggage here i was like okay well i
wonder if they're going to go in my
suitcase i didn't i thought i would just
run through an x-ray not a big deal well
um there's two dudes and
while look one guy's looking at one one
guy's looking at the other i just kind
of open mine up and i just [ __ ]
uh i shuffle something and then the guy
gets up and leaves the other person goes
hey hey and i go what because he went to
go get more security because i saw all
this [ __ ] pot in my bag and i was
like [ __ ] so i just grabbed it and i ran
out of that room and i took off down the
terminal to a bathroom and like [ __ ]
through it all through it all the way i
come back and there's three of the big
[ __ ] security dude
authority dudes in there and um they
don't find anything like hey what's
going on yeah they obviously find
anything so i'm like okay maybe i'm cool
maybe i'm cool and then i get in the car
they lock everything up and i get in the
car and now they're driving us on the
tarmac to the airplane just to skip the
gate and everything and i'm like we're
cool we're cool and then right when we
get to the pla right before we get to
the plane a cop car was right behind us
i'm a tarmac and i was like
[ __ ] i hope they're not here for me like
i don't know what they're here for you
know but then all of a sudden like we
get on the plane and that call card just
parks and they come on and then they're
on the plane looking i'm like [ __ ] i
hope they're not here for me still you
know and that's all cool and that didn't
happen so then we're flying and then
right when we land my security guard um
goes um
he goes you just go straight to the van
don't get your luggage you know
and so i did that and turns out they put
these stickers i don't know existed on
my luggage it says the letters d e which
means drug enforcement
so they just if they think there's
something there they stick it and they
call ahead and so if you see cops at a
baggage claim waiting around they might
be looking for that sticker they'll grab
that luggage it's and so like and that
happened so my bag came out with drug
enforcement stickers on it and my
security guard my my bodyguard did just
rip the stickers off and took it because
he knew what to look for um so it's kind
of [ __ ] what a great story that was
yeah well it's just like really
enjoyable but you know what's stupid
about it it's [ __ ] pot it's like dude
this isn't like
i mean dude this is like this literally
the one thing that doesn't kill you and
doesn't addict you and doesn't really
[ __ ] you up other than you eat a little
bit and say some dick jokes but like
it's so [ __ ] like the whole thing
around weed and yeah you know did you
did you have any cool places where you
used to try to smuggle drugs and
different things like
usually
no like uh
it's i was always i was never pulling
that [ __ ] like international like the
last thing you want to do is go to jail
and [ __ ] peru or something not that
we ever toured peru but you found a dog
in prayer which is awesome um but so i
never did that um you just try and find
things there but i wasn't really into
i wasn't that gnarly about it like back
then like now i kind of go if i go on
tour like i would how do i get weird
it's so boring like i don't know what
i'm gonna do you know but um back then
it was like i i just wasn't that crazy
about it or i had prescription pills it
wasn't my thing because i broke my back
like i had like
multiple herniated discs and they broke
in pieces
tangled in my sciatic i was like on a
cane for like a year how did you break
your back well just long time playing
guitar hunched over and launch ramps
remember the launch ramps are so big
when we're younger yeah what the [ __ ]
were we thinking up in a slam like eight
feet bam over and over again and then
we're like maybe that wasn't the
smartest way to do it but it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude